[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello, Marvelites.
You are watching
"This Week in Marvel."
I'm Ryan a.k.a.
Agent M, and I'm so
excited to be sitting here
with Dan DeLeeuw, VFX supervisor
of Marvel Studios' "Avengers:
Endgame."
Dan, there's so many
amazing moments and shots
inspired by the
comics here in Marvel
Studios' "Avengers: Endgame."
I was looking at
SECRET WARS # 4, like,
the classic mid-'80s issue.
It had this-- when
you were younger,
like, that's impossible!
The Hulk's holding
up a giant mountain.
He's saving everybody.
But then you have that moment
in "Endgame," which was so cool.
Rhodey!
You're going through,
and you're looking back
at your old-- your favorite
comics and just kind of, you
know, taking those
ideas, in "Civil War,"
with Tony and Cap, you know.
When I start a film, it'll be,
you know, with a team, again,
with the previous team, I'll
find panels that I like.
And then let's make a folder.
And it's like, OK, this
is one of your shots.
This is one of your shots.
And then eventually, you know,
they don't shoot it that way.
Sometimes you're like,
OK, we're going to go
back and change that shot.
We're gonna change it
back into the panel.
There's, of course, Captain
America wielding Mjolnir.
Avengers, assemble.
That has happened a couple
of times in the comics.
But when did you find out that
that was going to be a shot
you guys get to put together?
When you saw it
in Ultron, you know,
when he just kind of, you
know, half picks it up.
And you know, the debate
is whether he's worthy,
he's not worthy yet or--
it's one of the first things
we started pre-visiting, right?
Share your favorite
scenes first,
and you kind of go nuts, right?
They want something
that's, you know,
two-minutes long, three-minutes
long, five-minutes long.
You do something
that's 20-minutes long.
You pull up-- you pull
the best beats out of it.
And does it look
good in the film.
You have years and
years of history.
But there's some really
more recent moments,
the hail Hydra
moment from "Captain
America, Steve Rogers."
That was right before
"Secret Empire."
Trust me.
Hail Hydra.
RYAN PENAGOS: Or even
Cap fighting Cap,
which has happened multiple
times in the comics.
But recently that
happened in SECRET EMPIRE.
DAN DELEEUW: Mm-hmm.
RYAN PENAGOS: Or seeing
Rescue, like, amazing moment
with her and Tony.
But that's only from
INVINCIBLE IRON MAN, which
is within the last 10 years.
Are there specific areas
you're looking at you?
Or do you look at any
bit of Marvel history?
You do a deep dive, you know.
And then you just kind of--
you find the pieces that are
going to play the best for you.
And I mean, I think
that's, you know--
that's-- that's the point.
You look at these
films, and you look
at for a multitude of reasons
why these are successful.
But they're successful because
you love the characters,
and you love the
comics, and kind
of bringing in just
those moments for fans
when they're going
to recognize it.
And again, it's the best part.
Dan, part of the
journey is the end.
And that's the end
of this episode
of "This Week at Marvel."
Thank you so much
for being here.
And everybody watching
and listening,
make sure to pick up
Marvel Studios' "Avengers:
Endgame" on digital now.